Believe It or Not There is actually a
lot of news today other news we can tell
you about including the first of six
funerals for the victims of Monday
school shooting in Nashville and
authorities have released a 9-1-1 calls
from inside the school as the shooting
unfolded and we have to tell you they
are extremely upsetting and disturbing
they include at least one call from a
teacher who is hiding in a closet with
her students Mark straussman has the
latest from Nashville
minutes after the shooter entered the
Covenant School on
police dispatchers received a flurry of
hurried 911
behind the hushed voices sirens and
crying
try quiet I don't know
a woman Sheltering in an office told
dispatch at least one staff member in
the building carried a firearm we do
have
or it would be attacking
that are whose job it is for security
but I don't
I mean we don't have security guard but
we have a
staff it's unclear if any school staff
had weapons that morning
on Thursday three days after those
terrifying moments parents and students
rallied outside Tennessee's state
capitol in Nashville
before bringing the protest inside
[Applause]
where the republican-led legislature was
back at work for the first time since
the shooting
inside the packed rotunda state troopers
cut back demonstrators pleading for new
laws limiting access to guns
Evelyn Dickhouse will be buried later
today one of three children gunned down
in their own school all of them nine
years old
for CBS morning's Mark Strassman in
Nashville